[Musique]
dans son caddie ce matin ancienne élue
régionale observateurs de la vie
politique nous sommes sensibles à tout
ce qui touche à l'environnement à
l'énergie entre autres bonjour daniel
chomet bonjour aux auditeurs et
auditrices dément-il première ancien
membre du parti progressiste
martiniquais vous êtes aujourd'hui en
train de constituer votre convergence
progressiste martinique vous en êtes où
dans la constitution de ce nouveau
mouvement en fait convergence martinique
progressistes se veut être une réponse à
ce que je peux appeler la la crise des
partis traditionnels et qui veut sortir
des clivages droite gauche qui n'ont pas
su répondre j'ai envie de dire à
l'émergence d'un chômage de masse à
l'augmentation des inégalités mais aussi
sony de gauche des deux doit sembler une
coalition ça veut dire que votre volonté
les compétences des uns et des autres
au-delà de ces questions dogmatiques et
sortir et c'est le plus important
peut-être l'on débattra ce matin de la
conception qui veut aujourd'hui dans nos
partis traditionnels on se fonde sur la
nécessité qu'il y à nos providentiel
donc nous sommes en rupture avec ses
approches là et nous voulons incarner
une offre nouvelle logiciel un mode plus
pas un mouvement de plus une possibilité
supplémentaire c'est ce qu'on appelle la
richesse pour permettre aux martiniquais
qui considérant qu' il faut être
pragmatique agir concrètement sur terre
une problématique on part la question
des sargasses un second c'est que la
question des sargasses doit nécessiter
qu'il ya un préalable de gauche ou de
droite pour prendre nos responsabilités
et valoriser et traiter ces questions là
donc il ya un certain nombre de sujets
qui dépassent ces questions et je crois
que du point de vue de l'action publique
il faut s'inscrire de manière très
concrète au delà des clivages chacun
pouvant garder on va dire ça
son adn politique et aux veaux de la
convergence nous souhaitons mais
justement existe encore des adn
politique dans ce pays daniel chomet
selon vous vous savez le propre des
partis politiques c'est de viser un
idéal de mobiliser et des idées avec une
certaine politique j'en ai moi même une
qui sollicitait autour de deux piliers
essentiels
je suis de ceux qui considèrent que en
martinique on doit pouvoir avoir le plus
de responsabilités possibles sanaa ce
n'est pas si évident que ça il
en vingt ans trente ans d'autres princes
est l'exact contraire je suis aussi de
ceux qui considèrent que la martinique
doit résolument rentrée comme territoire
qui doit générer de la richesse de la
connaissance et de la compétence donc ça
lui ça veut dire qu'il faut investir
c'est d'être progressiste ça l'a défini
si j'ai une définition du progressisme
qui me sied particulièrement le
progressisme c'est c'est finalement ce
qui qui croît de manière très concrète
que la transformation des structures
sociales et politiques est de nature à
modifier le cadre de vie et générer une
plus grande justice sociale pourquoi
vous êtes plus au ppm vous savez pas ce
qu'ils disent un peu j'ai n'attendez pas
de moi que je règle mes comptes comme ça
mais je vais très très clair et très
france avc
c'est c'est aussi ma personnalité je
vous ai dit que je ressentais le besoin
de dépasser les clivages artificiels et
vous voyez bien que aujourd'hui l'ailé
les bruits qui lie à autour de ce qui se
passe dans notre parti au mime ou les ou
sein de la colonia de la coalition
grands sommets voit bien que l'attelage
les actions qui sont menées ne vont pas
au fond des choses pour deux raisons
parce qu'ils sont pas structurés et nous
on parlera sans doute sur l'idée d'un
projet partagé
il faut qu'il y ait un projet partagé et
je le dis très clair j'aime aussi sur
les ententes du genre de club ambitieux
à 2015 à clermont monsieur version il
faut que des martiniquais et je pense
que je peux incarner des zones de cette
génération sont de l'idée du culte de la
personnalité de l'homme providence dans
le rhode
vous êtes l'homme providentiel pour se
la joue surtout pas du tout je veux être
modeste contributeurs
dès lors que vous rentrez dans le
logiciel dans lequel il y à un homme
providentiel vous dévitalisées le débat
politique je l'écris récemment dans le
france antilles la question n'est plus
que dites vous mais qui a dit on on est
dans l'obsession de plaire au chef et
cela est un est un vrai obstacle au
débat au sein des partis au débat dans
les collectivités et au final à l'action
publique et et moi je considère qu'il
faut il faut revitaliser le débat
politique alors vu que j'ai quitté le pm
c'est vrai que ça se fait de manière
très brillante home vous savez j'ai été
pendant 15 ans monde une direction de
parenty j'ai pris une position publique
différente de celle de mon parti je n'ai
pas su faire passer vos
au script est suspendu j'ai été suspendu
par mail sans même avoir été convoqué a
commis un conseil de discipline sans
aucun rapport aux 110 longs je pense sur
les pratiques alors pour ma part j'ai
pris mes responsabilités j'ai considéré
que je n'étais plus à ma place même si
j'ai gardé des amitiés des infections
profonde que vous venez j'ai une grande
fierté de mon cheminement de mon
parcours politique maintenant résolu moi
je pense que il est important de donner
aux martiniquais une offre politique est
différente dans laquelle la question
nous apporte notre politique ne nous
enfermons pas bien au contraire est
perçu comme une régie daniel chow mais
si les choses se passent ainsi c'est à
dire l'homme providentiel à la tête
d'une formation politique
si ça se passe comme ça c'est parce que
les martiniquais l'ont voulu ils savent
comment ça se passe ils ne sont pas si
bête que cela ils savent très bien que
dans telle formation il y un leader
politique de l'autre côté il ya un autre
leader politique et ça donne des
élections et ça donne des vainqueurs ou
de perdants
je ne partage pas du tout votre votre
votre analyse je pense que les
martiniquais ce qui me demande c'est de
proposer des idées de les valider avec
donc il ya les élections pour dire ce
qu'ils veulent et de réaliser ce que
l'on fait ils n'ont jamais demandé de de
faire des parties des fans clubs ou des
clubs de supporters maintenant il
appartient aux autres de se sentir à
l'aise là où ils sont et considérer que
les modalités d'action dans l'eure dans
l'eure dans leurs organes et est propice
à cela
pour ma part je dis c'est ça c'est mon
analyse je considère que à la fois
l'oxydation autour des questions
d'appartenance politicienne comme
expliqué être est il sensé que des
hommes du mime ne puisse pas discuter
avec des hommes du ppm des hommes du rdr
que la compétence elle est partout il y
a aujourd'hui des obstacles naturels
janvier quasiment surnaturel qui font
que des sommes qui pourraient sur des
points convergent et c'est ça l'esprit
de convergence s'est pas excusé moi je
vais arrive au bout la convergence est
un grand migan s'il reconnaît que nous
avons des différences et réunir nos
compétences autour d'objectifs communs
c'est ça c'est singulier c'est cette
démarche dans laquelle moi je veux
m'investir de manière très apaisée très
concrète ce dialogue ou cenon dialogue
fait aux yeux et au su de tout le monde
les martiniquais ça ce qu'ils font en se
rendant régulièrement dans les échelles
l'isoloir lors des échéances électorales
en tout cas vous êtes actif c'est une
remarque je vous fais remarquer que de
plus en plus la moitié les électeurs
considèrent qu'il n'ya pas d'intérêt à
aller aux élections et cela est très
grave mais il s'en souviendra que dix
sept off c'est un vrai problème c'est un
vrai risque de d2 de dérivés ou
démocratique vous rendez compte
quand une décision majeure est prise la
moitié des électeurs restent chez eux
quand une majorité se dégage c'est la
moitié de la moitié donc sauf qu'il veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui nos instances à dire
que les piliers de la démocratie
s'appuie sur à peine 20 25 % du corps
électoral
c'est un vrai danger je pense qu'il faut
revitaliser le débat politique il faut
redonner du sens pour le système étant
celui là ça veut dire et vous y allez
vous avez déjà vous êtes déjà sur le
terrain à schoelcher en vue de cette
municipale de 2021
n'est ce pas aussi ça vous dit qu'il
faut accepter la nécessité de la
transformation
je le fais courageusement je le fais en
me donnant du temps je ne suis pas dans
des calculs et les systèmes à court
terme non je me donne les moyens
d'utiliser les la démocratie face à face
avec les électeurs martiniquais les
électeurs challes choix pour leur
démontrer qu'il existe une autre voie
avec celle cher dynamique et se dire
c'est votre mouvement niveau de celle
cercles vous allez privilégier le piste
celle là sur un plan très locales ont
bien vous allez chercher une sorte de de
résonance plus martiniquaise à travers
la septième en 2021
vous savez on peut on peut agir local
penser global je vais prendre un exemple
très court puisque le temps nous est
compté c'est la ville du marin
quand on nomme comme rodolphe désiré il
y a trente ans en tant que maire fait le
choix de tourner sa commune vers la mer
trente ans après cette commune est
devenue la capitale du nautisme du sud
de la caraïbe
il a servi sa commune il a servi son
pays je pense que être mais un ce n'est
pas renoncer à l'idée d'être un acteur
promoteur de la de l'excellence de son
territoire schoelcher de véritables
atouts nous avons un arrière-pays je lui
ai déjà dit où l'agriculture pourrait
devenir chercheur pour devenir la
capitale de l'agriculture biologique
avec la démarche est fondée
vous l'avez une façade maritime à après
deux à moins de dix minutes d'une
capitale on pourrait faire
développement de l'économie bleus vrai
levier de mieux vivre mais aussi
l'université pour universitaire a cessé
mais ses envies dire mais ça paraît
singulier mais c'est quand même sept
mille personnes c'est l'équivalent la
commune du vauclin dans toutes les
villes du monde où il y a une université
on développe ce qu'on appelle une
économie de la connaissance ça veut dire
que notre richesse
j'ai envie de dire n'est plus dans les
manches de croissance que pour nous de
préserver la banane je suis résolument
convaincu qu'au 21ème siècle ce qui fera
la différence de la martinique
il faut que notre antenne qu'il réussira
c'est la valorisation de la connaissance
du coup une commune comme celle cher qui
portent l'université doit véritablement
déployer une vraie stratégie sur ces
questions mais d'ici 2020 ici 2020 et il
peut se passer beaucoup de choses et
vous devrez composer notamment avec une
conseillère exécutive marinette et orpik
est une enfant de schoelcher qui siège
au conseil municipal de schoelcher sympa
une petite épine dans votre pied ça
c'est la diversité bon vous la nommez
elle a beaucoup à faire et beaucoup pas
réussir au sein de la 7e l'échelle
chéroy verrons ce qu'elle aura réussi et
seront en mesure de faire le bon choix
c'est la démocratie
aujourd'hui je ne veux pas m'inscrire
dans des querelles d'hommes
je pense qu'à un moment donné les gens
campagne pas du tout pas du tout la
campagne ça veut dire une des manches
qui se veut citoyenne en proximité
je ne viens pas avec livre fermé jeu
nous venons avec un livre ouvert
certes avec des pistes c'est le rôle de
confirmer que vous êtes en face certes
avec ce tiers temps avec des pistes
parce que nous sommes aussi en réflexion
et nous sommes des contributeurs parce
que nous sommes aussi des concitoyens
cherchera donc à pas les aurait dit nous
ça qui nota là où finit 10 et chercheurs
dynamique et solidaire donc c'est un
mouvement qui existait depuis 2008 et
jusqu'à considérer que c'est mon match
le ch peut incarner l'alternative bas
ben municipalité et vous pourriez avoir
une corde de plus à votre dans leur
prochain dans marche puisque vous invite
quand même supporters du candidat macro
lors de la présidentielle
on discutait pas avec en marche
martinique jeu je me mettais redis je
m'interdis de ne discuter avec quiconque
je discute avec tout le monde dès lors
que nous partageons sont que deux à
l'heure les valeurs démocratiques
je suis ouvert à toute discussion ce qui
figera
on va dire les coalitions les
convergences ça sera là comment
dirais-je
le projet des sinon le projet mobilisons
le projet identifiant les compétences
pour le porter parce qu'encore une fois
il ya le temps de l'élection de la
campagne vient le temps de la
responsabilité est sûre que ce soit des
gens moi faisons pas la condition que ce
soit derrière moi
pas forcément non pas du tout défaisant
de la compétence faisons de la
compétence un coeur de ce qui va
arbitrer la responsabilité il ya une
petite citation de fans au kiki qui me
plaît il appartient à chaque génération
dans une relative opacité d'accomplir sa
mission la trahir j'ai fait le choix
d'accomplir la mienne merci d'avoir été
ce matin avec nos daniel chaumier merci
bonne journée
merci à vous
[Musique]